hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
ja heute zum 9
nachdem er ist gerade der paket mensch
da war ich hab gedacht noch zu linken
bitte ich sehe oft in der werbung
irgendwie wenig fernsehen gucke oder
wenn ich durch die stadt laufe des
elektrons hat den neuenburger dieses
neue produkt diese neuen pommes dies
dass hier in jeden tag haben die
irgendwas neues ich weiß dass mcdonald's
jetzt nicht so der beste laden ist was
produktion angeht und was allgemein das
essen angehen und so und ich will das
auch überhaupt nicht alles gutheißen
aber ich hätte halt einfach mal lust so
zu mehr gold zu fahren einfach die
neuesten produkte die es gerade gibt
einfach so zu testen
[Musik]
macd hallo was ist ihr neuestes produkt
gerade wohl keiner soll ich dir den
bernern deinen kopf schule was ist das
neueste das neueste essen was sie gerade
im
verfügbar diese neue songs angesammelt
dann nehme ich den blick tasty baking
schicken die neu sind die karamell
nuggets weil das steht jetzt neu
die nehme ich auf jeden fall kann macht
der künstler und verkauft hat gesagt
dann nehme ich die frühlingsrollen sechs
aktiv als diese noch relativ neu also
steht neutral nämlich sehr gefasst auch
noch genau
ebenfalls mit seiner beziehung unten
chiquita bananen wer stellt so eine
scheiße wenn die sonne
also ich habe jetzt gerade das bestellt
was war so am neuesten ist also ich hab
sie gefragt was um die neuesten produkte
und das aller neuwagen durch gramm allen
tagen ausverkauft
ich weiß noch nicht wie karamell da geht
schmecken sollen ehrlich gesagt was zu
anderen weg scheint sich sprit alter
kann ich mit karte bezahlen und dann
gebt mir die halle an der kasse bezahlt
ich frag mich einfach wer fährt sie mit
donalds und bestellt sich einen blick
tasty baking schicken sechs
frühlingsrollen mit schließt und dann
noch happy face und zu trinken einen
milchshake gerade aber ihren das jetzt
mal ab
auch schon mal der weltbank schönen
starken hoch danke ich auch auf jeden
fall haben wir jetzt hier unsere sachen
bekommt hier sollte sich das alles drin
ein paar stunden später
da sind wir wieder hier auf mcdonalds
parkplatz werde ich die idee nach hause
zu fahren aber max meinte hey lasst euch
reden schönes wetter und das heißt vor
allem dass er sich dass jetzt nach hause
fahren das alles geschmolzen ist hierfür
ein paar bereits entschieden
er ist mit essen ist das erste produkt
meine damen und herren und zwar dass
dieser wir nochmal bananen kita
kunterbunt also schwamm rein und es
kommt nichts
es hat ja das ist überhaupt keine
werbung für mcdonald's gerade und muss
ich finde ich bezahlt dass ich jetzt
irgendwelche produkte getestet aber der
nachbarn aber schmeckt
hab ich ihn wieder schmecken wie
schmeckt der wein schmeckt
mir gefällt mir nicht in der banane die
würde ich auf jeden fall noch mal holen
ja wir haben uns gerade doch dafür
entschieden dass wir nach hause fahren
weil ein tisch frühlingsrollen bürger
schon schon schon sinnvoll max und ich
sind gerade auf dem rückweg und ich habe
jetzt dieses getränk noch ein bisschen
weiter gekommen weil ich will da freue
ich eine ausführliche food wie fury
zusammenstellen auf jeden fall kam jetzt
gerade so ein bisschen der banane
geschmack und wohin wir dass er so
vanillezucker schoko und jetzt ist der
drink gelacht aber einfach nur weil ich
halt banane über alles passe ja wir sind
wieder da diese wieder zu hause bei mir
angekommen wäre jetzt hier die drei
produkte die wir noch gekauft haben am
start und zwar einmal die ratings
clearing dann haben wir hier die hefte
freiheit also einfach pommes die so
aussehen die irgendwelche smileys wolke
cloud eigentlich von meinem logo oder
haben wir hier den big days i bacon
schicken
das sind jetzt alles eigentlich so
produkte so pommer ok frühlingsrollen
wusste ich gar nicht dass mac ist
überhaupt irgendwie am start ich dachte
jetzt sie haben so richtig krasse nach
sachen so karamell nachgezählt ich echt
gern mal probiert zu weil das klingt so
voll exotisch irgendwie aber sagt sie
fangen an mit dem ersten produkt uns mal
im big tasty baking schicken
das ist einfach ein bisschen mit chicken
dieser becken immer mit einer dslr
spiegelreflex kamera mit objektiv sobald
man die kamera richtig nach der frist
wagen noch einen zweiten bis meine damen
und herren noch nicht jetzt
meiner ansicht nach ist das ein
stinknormaler pictet cie becken also ich
meine jetzt kein großer unterschied ob
irgendeine bulette drauf so wird
schicken wahrscheinlich dass gegen aus
der politik ist dass ich muss sagen
diese geschmack von den banken hat mich
immer so wenn man früher immer wenn wir
irgendwie feiern waren in bielefeld oder
soll sich irgendwie 18 war 19 war oder
so bei mir halt danach immer besser
mcdonald's am jahnplatz alle bielefeld
erkennen wahrscheinlich den jahnplatz
und lehnen mcdonald's da ist jetzt nicht
so der flagge einzuladen aber auf jeden
fall hatten die nachts immer so richtig
viele banken darum liegen weil wir
halten ihr bestellter sondern nur so
schicken dann habe ich halt mal
mitgenommen und daran erinnert mich an
diese afterparty biedefeld sachen hier
der bürger ist auf jeden fall ganz geil
eigentlich muss ich sagen also der
banken ist jetzt nicht so dass der krise
ist auch noch nicht so richtig
geschmolzen und der schmeckt eigentlich
noch gleich ich mich also eigentlich ist
ja auch nicht so gefällt aber da stand
auf jeden fall dran dass der jetzt neue
civic das becken schicken weil mir kommt
es allerdings zu einem nächsten produkt
wo ich gar nicht wusste dass es
überhaupt ein mac ist im laden verfügbar
es uns gar keine heizung wir haben hier
erstmal eine chili sauce untersteht
schauen ich hasse schafe produkte
bestimmter gab sagen meine fresse ich
nehme jetzt mal so eine frühlingsrolle
erfolg vom aussehen muss ich sagen die
sehen jetzt nicht so appetitlich aus ab
denn die scharfe chili sauce
die schau geschaffen
vor darum dass die führungsrolle wieder
eingetrübt habe alter es ist fix um eine
geschmacksneutrale also fazit zu den
frühen freuen
und die sehen nicht sogar aus sie
schmecken wird endlich wie normale
frühlingsrollen weil irgendwo mit
willigen china buffet oder so also ich
hab schon deutlich bessere
frühlingsrollen gegessen ich habe aber
auch schon schlechtere frühlingsrollen
gegessen also diese frühlingsrollen
bekommen von mir auf der skala von 1 bis
10 würde ich sagen
6 ich hab die andere produkte mit
bewährter der big tasty baking ist
eigentlich ganz lecker ist aber ein
stinknormaler jason bateman schmeckt ist
aber auch nicht so hart geil deswegen
will ich die lizenz bekommt auch seine
sechs von zehn und der banane chiquita
milchshake bekommt sogar nachts also der
ist glaube ich ganz lecker aber ich mag
banane einfach nicht so gern wohl
gewartet hat um das wir bestellt haben
uns im letzten produkt was wir heute
testen werden und zwar die happy preis
da habe ich nämlich noch eine älter
diese soße brennt mir gerade alles weg
man findet sie es auch so bestellt ich
glaube jeder kennt wieso eigentlich
die standardsuche die man immer bei uns
bestellt egal ob zunahme ist
was also nicht als habe früher mal voll
viele pommes mit somit flury alles
gegessen was so ein raise eingeht und
das habe ich noch nie gehört macht jetzt
hier meine abstimmung was schmeckt gut
wenn die abstimmung dafür macht das aber
ich glaub ich vergessen
wir nehmen jetzt jemals einen happy
freies also ihr seht schon diesen
glücklich das ist einfach so ich bin
jetzt so ein bisschen traurig
details jetzt ok wetters eines
geldbetrages schmecken sogar echt geil
ich probiere noch mal so ein happy
freiheit hier natürlich weekends wir
sind wieder traurig wär vielleicht ja
auch gibt befreite sie wirken sind sie
erfüllen ihren zweck um das ganze jetzt
mal so ein bisschen abschießen fazit er
zu beurteilen ist aktiv fazit der pi
freising mein absoluter favorit die
schnecken sowieso nicht doch noch
kartoffelecken diese ketten kartoffeln
essen nein ich möchte nicht so den happy
face würde ich eine acht von zehn
aufgeben also die sind so ein bisschen
punkig aber das ist ja alles bei
mcdonald aber wenn man die ist dann ist
man selbst nicht mehr punktet dann
kriegt seine elf von zehn weil sowas hat
man abschließend zu beurteilen der bahn
schickt acht von zehn militärs bacon
sechs von zehn da sind wir bei 14 von 20
dann haben wir die frühlingsrollen auch
nur sechs funktionäre seit 20 von 30 die
hälfte 11 von zehn dann sind wir vom bei
31 von 40 punkten gut mcdonald's man
kann es schlechter machen
man darf dann aber noch mal ganz kurz
hier disclaimer mäßig meine damen und
herren wir heißen natürlich nicht die
ganzen produktionsmethoden von
mcdonald's gut
jeder soll selbst entscheiden ob er sich
vegetarisch ernährt vegan oder ob er
fleisch zu sich nimmt ich hatte einfach
nur lust weil ich sehr sehr selten bei
mcdonalds in hadamar hinzufahren und zu
sagen ey ich nehme er hat ganz gern mal
so die neuesten produkte die es
irgendwie gibt dann wenn meine frage wie
geht's ja ja nein ja fast ihr vom video
meine damen und herren natürlich gefahr
dass wir gerne an leichter
dass sich das eventuell mal von burger
king oder casey oder so mache und da
einfach mal hier und da kam mir die
neuesten produkte anschaut dass wir
vielleicht noch voller darüber fahren
und da hat uns die neuesten produkte
anschauen dann schreibt man in die
kommentare
macdonald und jetzt kommt das auto glas
wasser zu ihr vom video das war's jetzt
hier vom video hier können jetzt
jemanden kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten meinen job ausschenken jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und wenn
ihr schon abonnent seid könnt ihr auf
die glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]